mr speaker last week a government
minister was accused of sexually
assaulting a young man
i want to quote the victim's account
he says
he grabbed my ass and then he slowly
moved his hand down in front of my groin
i froze
i accept that's not easy listening
but it's a reminder to all those
propping up this prime minister just how
serious the situation is
he knew
the accused minister had previously
committed predatory behavior but he
promoted him to a position of power
anyway
mr speaker
that individual the uh on member for
tamworth no longer has the conservative
whip he no longer has a a job he is no
longer as soon as i was made aware of
the allegation that he has just read out
mr speaker the complaint that was made
uh he lost uh his um he lost his status
as a conservative mp and he is now the
subject uh mr speaker of an independent
investigation to the uh complaints and
grievances uh panel and that is entirely
right i want to say to him uh mr speaker
i want to say to him that i abort
bullying and abuse of power anywhere
in parliament in this party or in any
other party
none of that explains why he promoted
him in the first place
and we've heard it all before
we know who he really is
before he was found out
he's reported to have said
he's handsy
that's the problem
pincher by name
pincher by nature
now has the prime minister ever said
words to that effect and i'm not asking
for bluster and half truth we've all had
enough of that yes or no
prime minister mr speaker i'm not going
to trivialize uh what happened uh i i i
i yes mr speaker yes mr speaker
i'm not because the very serious
complaints have been raised against uh
the member for tamworth and they're now
being investigated mr speaker it is true
it is true that the complaint was raised
when he was in the foreign office and
the matter was uh resolved it's
absolutely true it's absolutely true mr
speaker that it was raised with me i
greatly regret that he continued uh in
office and
and i i've said that i have said that
before mr speaker i have said that uh
before mr speaker but he is now it is
now the subject of an independent
investigation and and that is the right
thing mr speaker
frankly i think the people of this
country would like also to hear they
would like also to hear about uh other
jobs that are held by people in this
country not least the 500 000 people we
got off welfare into work in the last
six months alone mr speaker those are
things that are making differences to
the lives of people up and down the
country and i'm proud of it
no one's hearing that no denial
and he says the matter was resolved when
he means it was upheld exactly and
they're all sitting there as if this is
normal behavior
when that young man reported his attack
to a government whip
she asked him
if he was gay
when he said that he was
she replied
that doesn't make it straightforward
that comment will sicken anyone who's
experienced sexual assault and then be
made to feel like they somehow asked for
it or who worry that prejudice means
their complaint won't be taken seriously
will he apologize for those disgraceful
comments on behalf of his government
i've i i've already said uh that i
regret very much that uh the uh member
for tamworth continued to hold office
after the complaint was made against him
in the
in the foreign office and uh it was it
was resolved in the fall office his
apology was accepted but clearly that
was not enough and in hindsight mr
speaker i should have realized that he
would not she would he would not
change however when it came to the
friday of last week and when i was given
the information that he's read out about
the complaint that was made against uh
the honourable member i acted
immediately mr speaker and i i took the
whip away from him and we will not
tolerate we will not tolerate that kind
of behavior in this or any other party
mr speaker and what we also want to do
is to help people up and down the
country with the things that also matter
to them like cutting their taxes mr
speaker by 330 pounds this year which is
what we're doing here
doesn't that just sum him up awful
behavior unacceptable in any walk of
life it's there for all to see
but he ignores it
it was the same when his ally was on the
take from the lobbyists
it was the same when his home secretary
was bullying staff
it was the same when taxpayers money was
being abused and it was the same when he
and his mates parted their way through
lockdown
anyone quitting now
after defending all that hasn't got a
shred of integrity
mr speaker isn't this the first recorded
case of the sinking ships fleeing the
rats
[Applause]
he talks he talks about
he he should hear what he's not saying
about him uh mr speaker he he talks
about he talks about in integrity and he
wanted he wanted to install uh the
member for islington north into number
10 right and mr speaker that's what
that's what he wanted to do imagine
imagine what our country and what the
world would be like now
he talks about integrity he voted he
voted 48 times to overturn the will of
the british people and take us back into
the european union and by the way
listening to his muddled speech the
other day that is exactly what he would
do again uh mr speaker
he talks about
integrity but mr speaker he has voted
time and time again against against
sanctions on criminals that would put
them behind bars this is the government
that is tough on
i'm sorry he's he talks about integrity
he is himself facing a criminal
investigation
and mr speaker which he asked me to
resign
what a pathetic spectacle
the dying act of his political career is
to parrot that nonsense
and as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
some self-respect
mr speaker
for a week
he's had them defending his decision to
promote a sexual predator
every day the lines he's forced them to
take have been untrue
first that he was unaware of any
allegation
untrue
then he was unaware of any specific
allegation
untrue
then he was unaware of any serious
specific allegation
and now he wants them to go out
and say
that he simply
forgot
but his whip was a sexual predator
anyone with anything about them would be
long gone from his front bench
[Applause]
in the middle of a crisis doesn't the
country deserve better than a zed list
cast of nodding dogs
well mr speaker uh it's when it's
exactly when
when times are tough when the country
faces pressures on uh the economy uh and
pressures on their budgets mr speaker
and when we had the biggest war in
europe for 80 years mr speaker
that is when that is exactly the moment
that you'd expect a government to
continue with its work not to walk away
mr speaker and to get on with our job
and to focus on the things that matter
to the people of this country and that
so we're not only cutting taxes uh today
mr speaker we're putting 1200 pounds
into every of one of the eight million
most vulnerable households in the
country mr speaker thanks to the
strength of our economy and thanks to
the decisions that we took mr speaker
which he opposed at the time
[Applause]
the only thing he's delivering is chaos
i started this session with a quote from
the young victim in all this how he
froze when he was attacked
when i was prosecuting rapists i heard
that from victims all the time
victims said they froze
because it's not about sex
it's about power
and the power the disgraced government
minister had was handed to him by that
prime minister
and he's only in power because he's been
propped up for months by a corrupted
party defending the indefensible
so it's no longer a case about swapping
the person at the top isn't it clear the
only way the country can get the fresh
start it deserves is by getting rid of a
lot of them
mr speaker
the difference
the difference between
this we've got to get through premises
questions prime minister
mr speaker the the difference between
this government and that opposition is
we have a plan and they do not
and we're getting on it they want to
focus on this type of issue mr speaker
we're going to get on with our jobs
we're going to control prices mr speaker
by not giving in to the union barons
they're paid by the union barons and
they're and they're proud of it
we were the first european country to
arm the ukrainians mr speaker i'm proud
of that and those guys mr speaker that
the party opposite the party opposite
not only do they want to put corp and mr
corbin into number 10 uh the memphis
into north but eight of them including
the shadow foreign secretary the shadow
deputy leader
six others six others voted to get rid
of our independent nuclear deterrent and
mr speaker today we are cutting taxes
we're helping half a million people into
work and thanks to the strength of our
economy we're helping people up and down
the country and we are going to continue
to deliver on the mandate i was given